no è il verde verde il rosso si
incolpano vicenda votato evitare come il
portone no oggi a grandi nuova etica
sono gut questa volta giocheremo con il
massimo degli impostori che è
impossibile
prima di iniziare oggi voglio comprare
in pezzi che voi vedete come sono ma mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace e se
questo video raggiunge i 15 mila mi
piace fare un altro torneo con voi ma
perché voi giocate con noi perché fra
poco condividerò il codice con voi e non
un ora di vedere che è battaglia farà
con tanti impostori o la maglietta rosa
quindi mi metterò road
vediamo cosa se è da comprare nei
capelli grassi scrivete ci furono i
commenti qual è il vostro colore
preferito dal personaggio di among us
scrivete solo questo per me è il rosa e
il viola sono i più belli e per te per
me i blu e il rosso sono i più belli
allora ci sono i cappelli natalizi
abbiamo
enna il cappello di babbo natale a un
osso tipo che carini vediamo cos'altro
c'è finito doveva per noi super amanti
degli animali o dobbiamo assolutamente
prendere un petto ma solo tipo tutti
anni però è giustamente stiamo nello
spazio nella navicella trascina quindi
abbiamo l'alieno la navicella nokia
l'altra famiglia a berlino versione blu
che per un ottimo però sto bene ma si
può cambiare colore lo facciamo giallo
come berlina o penso che devi per forza
tenere questo colore carino e un criceto
dentro la fonte ma è dentro la pallina
perché ovviamente non può respirare una
visione giusto sarà faccia un po perché
questo è un cane alieno a fini me perché
sono due perché poi dice che un bundle
vuol dire un pacchetto cioè con questo
tool complessiva e il cappellino via il
minime quell'uomo un personaggi nisticò
e questo personaggi instytut ma con i
capelli
vabbè richiede a voi cosa sono ancora si
allena
pilota tutti i mestieri
poi ecco i cappelli
allora diamo la corona sopracciglia
belli non so quale se facciamo così
questa volta ne scelgo io ho due evo
iscrivetevi di commenti quale comprare
per il prossimo episodio e comprerò
quelli più votati quindi bastati
scrivete un commento e poi mettete i
like ai commenti che vi piacciono di più
così capisco quale quello che vi piace e
cosa no io non so quale se andrews sono
tutti bellissimi
allora io prendo il minime con il
cappello minime che si ragazza allora
abbiamo condiviso il codice su instagram
estate già arrivando guardate io ho due
minime 1 in testa e uno che mi segue che
carini sono sempre più dieci fra poco
cominciamo chissà se sarà poi portare
questa questi impostori sicuramente
vinceranno gli impostori con la casa non
il massimo vedremo accaduto alla partita
roma no km perché voi chiuso forse
perché non abbiamo iniziato subito come
faccio ok ce l'abbiamo fatto sistema
problema in pratica a crashato tutto
perché dice che stavamo troppo tempo
senza inizieranno partita ma ora per
fortuna c'è un riuscito dovuto
cancellare adesso ci stiamo
eccoci e di dice ciao ciao mi ero
spaventatissimo ok siamo i salari al
volo
ok ok ci sono tre impostori
noi andiamo subito a fare le nostre
tasche non sappiamo vitale che cos'è
perché stiamo giocando separati quindi
potrebbe essere un impostore potrebbe
non essere un impostore non sia un reato
ormai dauno freghiamo ci ridate
svegliati privati avuto un corpo già tu
l'hai trovato molto sospetto che
sospetto edificio dove io ho trovato nel
reattore 1 che vitale ha trovato subito
il coro fondato dal reattore per per
modificare per aggiustarlo non e all
intera con me grazie arancione mi hai
difeso gli verrà in store è svolto blu
chi è blu sono i oblucki ma perche io
sono andato a giusto da aggiustare il
reattore non so il fatto di come
riportato subito il corpo mista di forme
e io voto te la loro vita le sas
no non è vero
l'uomo
ma è troppo sospetto che hai trovato
subito il corpo ricordatevi è un motivo
per questo aspettare se qualcuno trova
subito il corpo lo disse in modo un po
sospetto un motivo per sospettato ma
possiamo giocare in poster in meno a tu
puoi giocare da fantasma con il posto
libero bancario 2 imposto un aiuto aiuto
il suo aiuto di uomo di vediamo non
uccidetemi che sono qua giallo rosso e
arancione
vediamo quindi non sono sospetti bianco
e viola come mai non erano a sistemare
il reattore fast sospetti viola e giallo
o nero al bianco bianco e viola erano io
so chi sono gli altri impostori però
ovviamente non te lo dico
il viola quello che dicevi che ora è il
bianco forte vediamo in electric ha nel
bianco è stato il bianco a trovarlo io
ero alle telecamere io dico bianco tass
io sto chattando invece gli altri io
dico bianco perché il bianco l'ho visto
salire non ha sistemato il reattore
unite sotto il registro no non stiamo
registrando il bianco allora in due
prove erano gli altri a milano poco
non mancano due impostori uno stesso
busto questo sabotato le luci allora non
può essere rosso perchè rosso è qui con
me sono io che ho subito io sei morta
ero posto titolare sabotare i abbiamo
sbattuto poi romano di serra non è
possibile perché continuo a giocare da
fantasma ma io non sono diventato tutto
pure avevano saputo il rettore non ti
permettere 96 molo già sabotato non me
lo fa al riso a votare età che prima
però sabotato sicurezza allora bianco
rosso e giallo sembra che stiano facendo
le loro tasse
sta facendo un sacco di tusk io continuo
a sabotare a loro la mia task preferita
[Musica]
perché riesco mai a fare una visita
dello shouf posto giusto può dare rio
doce troppo veloce più lesti a tutte le
tasche
no non puoi start e neppure dalla
navicella andò in arancione rapaccini
anche fatta tassi un po complicato
asincroni ok hp sta continuando stato
trasmette rimanere un fantasma
io devo aiutare i miei amici il posto
che gusto ci sarebbero fra d'amico
indizio
no non te lo posso dare sì abbiamo vinto
noi impostori
giallo e bianco nuova partita o perché
sono diventato tutto nero stiamo
ripartendo non guardare noi stessi
scooter spesa perché ci sono tre
impostori qualcuno mi ha rubato in rotta
andiamo andiamo andiamo impostori
dobbiamo andare a sistemare le luci poi
piace giocare di più come impostori o
come fiume scrivetecelo nei commenti
fa una partita l'hanno già vista gli
impostori forse troppo difficile contro
imposto molto salato io sono bruno si no
dico questo perché perché così facciamo
più tasti insieme no così siamo tutti
crumetti facciamo tutte le tasche
insieme quindi se facciamo tutte le
tasche insieme vinciamo 4 gli impostori
sto dicendo solo questo
ok evitare decisamente di votarlo è vero
che certo non sono stato io ma ora
inizierò a pedinare si no quella cosa
strana di quando giochiamo assieme a voi
e che non mi uccide mai nessuno io
capisco che volete che rimango in gioco
però uccidetemi pure tranquillo mi piace
fps anche tre fantasmi divertente anche
se fantasma
e non sono stato io questa volta
lo dico subito verde ha riportato
arancione dove cibo è stato verde a
riportarlo allora io dico blu non sono
stato io do minerale mentre tutti
impostare ma non sono stato io non viene
subito scrivere una scusa valida
incolperà votato vitale come il bottone
no no no non sono stato io sono stato
[Risate]
bellissimo testo partita vitale vitale
chi non ha votato il verde non ha votato
il che è molto fas
perché se il verde ha trovato il corpo
non ha votato e il verde lo scrive il
deputato nessuno che strano
vediamo
sì è vero sono un impostore quali sono
stato io ad ammazzare quello io ho
ammazzato il bianco corpo è stato
trovato in oggetto pure la verità è che
io non sapevo stato bianco lo sapete
dove sparito aiuto andiamo fuori tar
salvare in realtà ore
adesso so devo sabotare tutto qua grazie
ma perché si sempre imposta ora è tutto
fermo la destrà sono gli scanner
previste siamo in tre e dobbiamo farcela
questa è la penultima partita e la
prossima è l'ultima partita quindi non
dobbiamo far vincere gli impostori ma di
una volta e io sto sabotando tutto
pratici mai dichiarate fa tutto bene
sono anche ribadito dai dimmi almeno chi
sono gli altri sbagliato ma non sbaglio
questo giallo è comparso dal nulla o
molto fa mai manca solo una tac non è
stato continuo ha messo a buttare tutto
ma ti perdono tanto così vitale
si ok sono riuscito a rientrare ma
perché sono gay che mi avete rubato
sette colori rimasti su marte base si
parte ha scelto il nero tutto pur di non
c'era niente contro l air inverno come
quello che a me porta sfortuna
questa volta ce la dobbiamo fare con
cominciare a sopportare ha dimezzato lo
dirlo e non altro questo è l'ultimo
partita quindi dobbiamo impegnarci
proviamo vincere questa volta ma io sono
il suo store e ordinata sono cattivo
cattivo il posto re sempre sempre a
votare me e poi guardo impostare anche
questa volta non è chiuso dentro casa
privata e provoca peso ed un impostore
che sia chiuso dentro ma io questa cosa
delle forze non l'ho mica capito come
funziona questa task e ossigeno
spingerò non so perché il modo in cui
parla vitale che sembra nuovamente same
viola era con me no such modicanità
questa volta non cominciare a mirko
videogiochi sento libera
non voglio neanche guardare io sono io
amo capitale
no no anche rossa di no dai
abbiamo fornito basta antifatica te ne
pentirai questa volta io ero no ho
forato vediamo forse non vengo espulso
questa volta a meno male ero io
vedremo non scomposte di poter ogni
turno non possono essere sempre gli ufo
[Musica]
guardiamo le camere di sicurezza
due persone in altri peccato che non mi
dice i colori questo che adesso non mi
di cervicale in italia che cosa ha
votato il reato
guarda che bello i costumi di julie
bianco con la carta igienica in testa è
bellissimo ma questi impostori non
l'amazzone adesso sono che cos'è che
perdiamo un po le camere di sicurezza
per divertente per le camere allora
viola sta salendo
io d'ora in poi farò il controllore su
cui faccia leste sono sempre tutti quasi
abbiamo ambientale mi voglio esplorare
voglio trovare qualche corpo vediamo
questi impostori sono tanto bravi
finalmente questi impostori hanno ucciso
qualcuno
non sono stato io
santamaria cosa l'italia molto strano
che i subito che non sono io ma oggi ha
votato non mi dire che il bianco voto
tornare di nuovo subito gialla fast
dicono italy dice bianco no no di stallo
vediamo biancoceleste stavano sempre
assieme quindi incide poco a parte li
approva con bianco a noi celesti è stato
ucciso
proviamo con bianco o no forse novo rosa
bianco
tutti quanti abbiamo votato bianco
allora chi giallo perché sa cosa su
bianco giallo rosso rosso accusato
bianco hanno fatto già modelli che
continuo le mie tasche
sperando di novita dai tre impostori di
temi come si fanno ad aprire e chiudere
le porte lorusso feto faifi bello niente
certo marrone ra qua che guardando solo
già prima insieme allora sì che tutte e
due fa
non è vero eccomi all aeroporto di ma
meola e dietro di me in passato era noto
come il viola adesso sto passando video
per cui questi importanti non uccidono
nessuno oppure solo una tecnica per
rendere più lentamente controllo guidato
il grosso hanno trovato chi l'ha trovato
viola
hai detto che hai visto viola uscire da
un vento una botola mi è sembrato a chi
ha incolpato il bianco prima il rosso no
ma il rosso è stato ucciso non può
essere lui può essere siamo pochissimi
siamo solo noi siamo rimasti solo due
crew mail e tre impostori via la sas gip
feriti speriamo che sia più aiutato
viola il voto pure io tutti mi hanno
votato sì ma chi è chiusa la porta massa
come si fanno ad aprire la porta dove
deve averla chiusa allora dici no ma
forse l'ha chiusa per poter farla tasca
perché che non ha fatto le tasche ancora
infatti manca il cui qualcuno che non ha
finito le tasche altrimenti avremmo già
vinto perché non venissero l'età
secondo me il giallo ma no che chi fa il
sabotaggio che chiude le porte
probabilmente
via male fatto tutti hanno tutti
sospettato del giallo daira scopriremo
se abbiamo vinto
vabbè mi avete scoperto
non era mai successo che qualcuno
mettesse di apporto è in prima che
succede mi sono fatto schifo però cioè d
abbiamo vita e vivace di nuovo e rosa
ultima partita speriamo speriamo di
vincere che questa volta ricordare senza
un corpo ok nell'ultima partita questa
volta gli impostori sono molto attivi
dove raga vediamo sospetti ho
l'impressione che questa partita finirà
molto brutta perchè bianco ha già votato
sta giocando da mongoose mentre guardo
among us nella vita reale multitasking
il verde ma state registrando
chi ha già votato giulia già votato il
bianco quindi io voto il bianco gli è
scappato invece vediamo io non sospetta
nessuno quindi in carrozza sospetto che
vediamo che hanno votato non ci credono
due hanno votato me ma perchè non sono
[Risate]
bastati 20 c sempre che sono sospetto
tutti quanti mi votano che allora
continuiamo a fare le vasche le tasche o
no mi hanno ucciso
veramente mi hanno ucciso
non mi puoi dire chi è
no non te lo devo red dicono ma il red
ha chiamato il meeting ok votiamo red
speriamo noi il verde verde il rosso si
incolpano vicenda del rosso sarà il
verde ricordiamo nella ricordiamoci del
verde ei no tav in ciao alla prossima è
stato bellissimo giocare io scrivo
perché breve che vi divertite tanto
giocare con noi
i miei preferiti
benissimo troppo divertente queste
partite mi raccomando è stato un bel mi
piace se volete anche voi giocare con
noi siamo altri episodi che mi piace
ravera 4 casellina qui caso delle nostre
altri video caricate su quella che
preferite